[Music]
cryptids
[Music]
people from all over the globe have
managed to capture images and videos
this is like the fakest looking security
camera footage
wow that's a vfx
the things that we can use to prove that
it's vfx all happen at the end here
nico hi sam it is
come to my attention
that the world
has
another plague on its hands oh no
cryptids
the city of amarillo texas is asking
folks to guess what is this thing so on
previous debunk episodes here we have
covered the uaps and ufos that live in
the skies above us but there are still
so many paranormal moments captured on
footage that happen here on the ground
everything from ghosts
orbs and today cryptids you may have
heard of the phrase cryptid before but
if you haven't it comes from when you
combine the word creepy and dude you get
encrypted
so cryptids i believe the stages they go
from invisible cryptid to orb to
whisp
to transparent humanoid form and then
they physically manifest finally as
encrypted fortunately
people from all over the globe have
managed to capture images and videos and
so today we have a wide array of clips
documenting cryptids in all of their
various forms all right so we're going
to sit back and we're going to apply our
knowledge of camera trickery visual
effects special effects we're going to
try to figure out if what we're looking
at has been faked or it's something real
on camera that's unexplainable are you
ready for this hit me
let's go
oh wow
isn't that creepy
like a little praying mantis just
just creeping in the driveway something
like hanging from his mouth or something
like a weirdly shaped head
where are the arms
he the thing they got out of his head i
think it's just his other arm oh
like this you sent me turns that you
just we're just seeing his hand be like
yeah
i'm not just a dude in a morph suit
[Laughter]
the creature slash person looks really
skinny and like lanky and looks like
their head is like like almost like a
rectangle but i have a feeling that's
just really compression doing a number
on it
because boy is this compressed but i
really think this is just a person
in a morph suit or potentially even
naked but they're not really going
anywhere or looking at anything like it
feels like they're acting they're just
doing an intentionally creepy walk yeah
as we know like cryptids like the way
they act is much different than this
i mean i would imagine they're stealing
stuff out of your cupboards you know
they're they're like putting like little
totems underneath your pillow when you
sleep you know it's like that's clearly
what they do it's not bad though it's
not bad though it's it piques my
interest though you know you watch it
and you're like ooh all right i'm i'm
into this let's give it a final call is
this a cryptid or crypt didn't crypt
didn't
[Music]
so this video captured obviously by
security cam footage shows a man being
attacked by a cryptid in its proto form
aka a completely transparent cryptid
it's very shocking
whoa oh
is that fancy breakdancing
or is that a mysterious force
let me see let me see his leg get lifted
up again
so a little slippy do
down he goes
throws that pink towel so right here
that scoot
yeah you won't be able to move like that
so something has to be pulling him
around something is holding on to his
leg it has like all the signs of a wire
pull because that is a gym they do have
like clearly it's structurally sound
enough to hang like you know load
bearing like ropes and stuff like that
so you could totally mount like a wire
or something in that area when he gets
lifted up by the leg it looks like it's
a rope pulling on his leg and you'll
notice the leg pulls him to a spot and
kind of goes up there so if you were to
take the motion of say a rope coming
from a pulley on the ceiling and going
down the way he gets moved and pulled
over to that spot and he's being pulled
straight up there that's the motion you
would have from a rope being on the
ceiling if it was a person like pulling
his leg along he would just be scooting
along the floor he wouldn't get like
scooted right to the spot in his leg
would go straight up and be like pulled
straight up also once he gets back up
and he runs away you can see it with his
motion where he's like favoring that
foot but then again a ghost
tried to dislocate it so my guess is
that there would just be somebody
pulling them around and they're just
painting them out which is like
the oldest trick in the book when it
comes to visual effects can i have proof
of this visual effects no it's still
compressed i don't really have anything
i can particularly point to it's clumsy
ghost like clearly the ghost is there to
get this guy
and yet he spends his time milling
around bumping in the stuff tripping
over balls
like going like what does this button do
poop and turns off a light you know it's
like
go for the kill
i guess the crib didn't crypt
that's a crib
is this thing on
okay we actually have our own cryptid
problem in the studio there's been
reports of hauntings going on
every nook and cranny of the studio
seems to have some weird little janky
spirit in it these spooky little guys
are everywhere
oh my god herpes are here now these
hauntings are really starting to affect
workplace productivity no one can get
anything done anymore around here
luckily thanks to today's sponsor raycon
using these everyday earbuds and their
noise isolation feature i've been able
to tune out the cryptids in the studio
i'm now immune to these hauntings
raycon's everyday earbuds look feel and
sound better than ever with optimized
gel tips for the perfect in-ear fit
these earbuds don't budge at all on top
of noise isolation mode they also have
an awareness mode that lets you listen
to your favorite music but also hear the
world around you another thing about
raycons is they come in this awesome
wireless charging case they offer eight
hours of play time and 32 hours of total
battery life that means that i can
literally have these in all day and have
a full productive work day undistracted
and the cherry on top is that braycons
are priced just right you get quality
audio at half the price of other premium
audio brands listen i gotta go before
the kryptons get more bold but if you
want to get a pair of your own raycon
everyday earbuds go to buyrecon.com
corridor crew you'll get 15 off your
order that's byracon.com
quarter crew for 15
off your order
thank you later oh my god
all right we got one more invisible
this is like the fakest looking security
camera footage like the lights are on
like the lights are literally on and
it's green like night vision but the the
light you can see the lights on you see
the light casting like
oh i got the door handle oh dramatically
time door handle right when it moves it
cut away it's like did it go through
that door handle
maybe maybe could it does another person
have done that easily
yeah just as easily just as easy more
plausibly
ooh a shadow oh
unexplainable
[Laughter]
yeah it's probably i think that's a mask
that's like after effects you're right
it looks like after effects yeah there's
nothing about that that like
significantly changes the lighting of
the environment or shows that the shadow
is being cast from any physical source
so obviously yes
our options are a a ghost b after
effects
the chair push come on roll that chair
give me a chair
oh there's the chair
being pulled on a rope now if these
chairs didn't move in a straight line
towards a fixed point i would be more
intrigued as it currently stands just
like the guy's foot they're going to a
straight point this is a very young
cryptid who's just discovered his
psychic powers and it's like
experimenting
ooh the tv the monitor turned on
wow that's a vfx
wait let's go to go see it again let's
do it again
[Music]
so first props for them for doing
reflections in the window good for them
so why is that vfx a lot of screens
turning on even though they so lovingly
did the screens in the reflection well
because the screens cast zero light into
the environment once they turn on turn
on any screen and look at the
environment it casts light into it also
lcd screens don't have static yeah
unless they're like switching to a
source uh
like like an analog like receiver
that doesn't have a signal like there's
no way static on a screen is from back
in the day when your tv was hooked up to
an antenna and antenna would receive
radio waves electromagnetic waves and
turn those into an image when it wasn't
dialed into a channel basically a
broadcasting frequency it was literally
just getting the random electromagnetic
frequencies from space which represents
itself as random pixels on your tv aka
noise all right that's cool you know
what a fun little project for some
people to do in that office yeah on
their off hours crypt didn't [ __ ] didn't
[ __ ] didn't
this might look like an ordinary gym to
you but at night it's far from normal so
cryptids they start invisible but then
they finally gain a spirit a spirit orb
of sorts and that is i think their first
manifestation kevin installed those
cameras a few months ago but it wasn't
very long until he was alerted to some
intruders
very strange intruders
what is this freaking like orbs
[ __ ]
thankfully they brought experts in to
say these are actually friendly spirits
it's not uncommon
for
apparently industrial buildings to get
perceived supernatural experience local
ghost expert mason winfield law
enforcement appears powerless to stop it
law enforcement is powerless to stop
these friendly spirits what
oh my gosh this is very clearly dust
just drifting in front of the light yeah
it's like it's an old building they turn
on the ac so security cameras have
infrared leds right around the lens so
when stuff goes by the camera it catches
the light from what's basically a bright
infrared flashlight right beside the
camera lens so things are super bright
when they're right in front of the light
so literally dust or bugs
that looks like dust to me
it's just blown by the lens
it's out of focus it's bright so it
looks like a freaking bokeh a circle
it's a crappy camera so they're leaving
trails
you know everybody at the news station
knows this is dust like like everyone
here knows it's us and they're like hey
the news com they're sending news people
down here and some like ghost experts so
everyone come to the gym today so we can
all box in the background
cryptid and [ __ ] didn't yeah
these cryptids the journey they started
invisible they've manifested into spirit
orbs and now they're building out their
mortal form all right are you ready
they're not quite solid yet
but they're getting there
[Music]
this is a person in a bed sheet and
composited into the shot kind of looks
like it once again venturing into
speculation territory could you do this
with visual effects absolutely very
easily
is there anything that indicates it's
being visual effects yes it strikes me
as somebody having like recorded the
shot twice and then like comping them
together now we're seeing like true 3d
motion there you see how it's like
below the dash it kind of like moves up
and over so it's like if you're to do
that you know you have to track your
shot like you have to track your
background footage and then you have to
add this on top but in a way you could
totally do that with two plates there
the perspective doesn't change very much
it's effectively a 2d effect yeah you
get the you start the shot and you film
the ghost and then the camera is on the
dashboard locked off then you have the
person go across that's your element you
can cut it out do whatever you want with
it just motion track it back to the shot
this is a very easy shot to do with
visual effects the things that we can
use to prove that it's vfx all happen at
the end here here at the end the ghost
actually goes over a bush that's
supposed to be
closer to camera and that's weird um and
then it's the masking behind the trees
here once it crosses the behind the
trees you can see that there's this like
very super sharp dark edge now granted
it's a headlight coming from the
perspective of the lens theoretically
our our light wrap wouldn't be that dark
on the edge but still it's a very
defined edge there for what's otherwise
very blurry in compressed video it does
strike me as being odd i like how the
ghost is authentically walking like it
doesn't float yeah it walks a walking
ghost
[Laughter]
yeah that's a [ __ ] didn't [ __ ] didn't
all right nico here's our first fully
formed cryptid displaying some classic
cryptid behaviors
[Music]
looking at that weird creature there
what is that
is that a
looks like she's digging with her hands
oh hell yeah i'm down for this this is
creepy and spooky
yeah it's the cryptid what are they
doing in the graveyard
it's pretty creepy yeah so not a
creature just a human being just a
crackhead but the human being is doing
creepy things i like it it's just a
creepy dude
that means he's a cryptid
we got a cryptid there like yeah just a
guy
or someone maybe on drugs someone who's
you know dealing with a mental health
problem
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh this is a good setup for a creepy
video so let's see what happens
oh
monster squeal that wave i'm on the edge
of my seat it's about to get it's about
to get scared oh what is that
dude
what is that
is that a full-size guy
he's just clinton jones
[Music]
yes look at that it's like literally his
friend with like freaking long underwear
or something on at first it was really
convincing and then it's just like a
dude with his underwear that's a
handcraft from half-life is that a
predator mask you can see it falling off
so he like pushes on it it's like i've
got an adjustment mask
[Laughter]
they made the mistake of having come too
close to the light wonderful video i
quite enjoyed it it was excellent all
the way until the reveal the crypt
didn't crypt didn't
on that note
would you like to see the final clip i
would love to see it something
completely
unexplainable something so bone-shelling
you may never be able to unsee this
scripted
oh no
i hope when my boy is like four years
old that he has a t-shirt on his head
and does this in my driveway
i know literally that's a boy with a
towel on his head and it's millions of
views
that's the dobby mystery been solved
let me
say the description three months after a
creepy creature that resembled dobby
from harry potter was captured on a home
security camera the question remains who
or what
was it some viewers noticed similarities
to dobby while others theorized it could
be gomez's nine-year-old son wearing
underwear on his head inside edition put
it to the test by placing underwear on
bobby's head and then asking him to do
the chicken dance
[Laughter]
he's like all right put this underwear
on your head
oh that's him
look at that skinny little guy it's
totally his totally that kid look at
that look at the evidence
[Laughter]
you know what perhaps the inside edition
for doing some hard investigative
drawings yeah they brought the story
honestly the fact they went out there
and did that and they got the same shot
is rad is it bobby or dobby that's the
shirt
i want one of those shirts i'm gonna i
want to bother your dummy shirt too
i would love a bobby dobby shirt
all right if anyone knows where you can
get bobby or dobby shirts please send a
few to court or digital we would so much
appreciate that we'll wear them on the
next debunk
not a lot of convincing stuff out there
no there's nothing convincing out there
yet that we've seen yeah i think we
decrypted those cryptids today some good
creepy stuff good visual effects these
clips are incredible to watch they are
eerie they're spooky they're super fun
to debunk and if you have anything
that's unexplainable and you would like
us to review on this show send it to
debunk
quarterdigital.com all right oh [ __ ]
dude
[Music]
[Laughter]